8 2022 a donc été une année
météorologique qui a pulvérisé bon
nombre de records de température mais
aussi des phénomènes climatiques
extrêmement voire violent d'ailleurs
extrême voir violent font-ils
s'inquiéter davantage de cette douceur
exceptionnelle que nous vivons
actuellement c'est l'une des questions
que je vais poser à notre invité bonjour
Jean-Marc Jaco ici bonjour vous êtes
professeur Romy président du chief du
shift projet expert climat et vous venez
de publier une bande dessinée intitulée
Un monde sans fin aux éditions d'argot
qui est déjà vendu à plus de 500 000
exemplaires des marrons simplement avec
les températures de la nuit dernière du
premier au 2 janvier donc 13 degrés à
Paris très à Strasbourg 18 à Pau on
dirait plutôt des températures du mois
de mai ou de juin est-ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter de cette douceur et surtout
comment l'analyser vous est-ce que j'ai
le droit de me dire de vous dire pardon
qu'il faut s'inquiéter de la question
vous êtes là évidemment qu'il faut
s'inquiéter de cette douceur
alors là en fait la douceur en elle-même
instantanément elle va tuer personne les
gens se disent ah c'est plutôt sympa etc
par contre il y a d'autres êtres vivants
qu'il apprécie moins
particulier tout une partie de la
végétation nous vivons dans un pays
tempéré dans lequel une bonne partie des
arbres paye à perdre leur feuille hiver
là ils ont besoin de froid l'hiver pour
bien se porter au printemps et voilà
c'est ce qu'on appelle la vernalisation
ils apprécient pas ça du tout un climat
trop doux va favoriser la survie des
ravagesurs qui vont leur compliquer la
vie ensuite pendant la période pendant
le printemps il était et ravageurs
les virus les insectes etc enfin toutes
les petites bêtes qui font que voilà les
petites bestioles des petites bestioles
voilà qui vont qui vont rendre la vie un
peu plus difficile aux végétaux
et puis voilà donc c'est un climat qui
ne va pas être bon pour tout le monde et
puis j'ai envie de dire c'est parce
qu'ane anecdotique parce que c'est un
luxe mais ça complique un peu aussi un
tout petit peu la vie aux gens qui
vivent des sports d'hiver à la montagne
bien sûr comme vous avez pu le constater
probablement récemment alors est-ce que
c'est phénomène que nous connaissons en
ce moment ont un caractère exceptionnel
oui et non
cette exceptionnel au sens où c'est
inédit donc en quelque chose d'inédit
nous arrive on se dit toujours cette
exceptionnel et la réponse est NON au
sens où ça s'inscrit dans une tendance
et la tendance c'est que en fait la
normale n'existe plus ça c'est quelque
chose qui est très perturbant mais qu'il
faut bien avoir en tête la normale
n'existe plus quelque chose sur cette
notion parce que c'est très important la
normale c'est quelque chose qui est un
état stable auquel vous revenez après
une perturbation votre taille normale
pour combien vous mesurez mais 75 un
mètre 80 on a le droit de livrer 70
c'est votre taille normale si un jour
par exemple il vous arrive Dieu sait
qu'elle problème qui fait que vous êtes
obligé de rester assis mais à votre
taille normale diminue mais dès que le
problème disparaît vous retrouvez votre
taille normale vous faites toujours un
mètre 77 est-ce que vous êtes là en ce
qui concerne en ce qui concerne le
climat son état normal c'est-à-dire
l'état stable auquel on revient après
une perturbation n'existe plus parce
qu'on a enclenché une dérive du système
climatique et quand le système dérive en
fait ça général n'existe plus je peux
prendre un autre exemple c'est si vous
avez un bout de tissu et que vous coupez
un centimètre chaque jour il n'y a pas
de longueur normal d'accord c'est très
clair bon et ben c'est exactement ça en
ce qui concerne le climat un certain
nombre de paramètres du système
climatique sont en train de dériver
notamment la température moyenne et donc
cette dérive à partir de maintenant fait
que l'État auquel on peut revenir après
une perturbation on a plus de sens ça
n'existe plus donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut il faudrait plutôt parler de
dérèglement climatique que de
réchauffement alors le réchauffement est
un dérèglement c'est voilà mais
effectivement on devrait parler plutôt
de dérèglement il y a même des gens qui
ont proposé de parler de crise
climatique alors crise pour nous c'est
quelque chose qui en général est très
aiguë dans le temps très très limité
donc pour quelque chose qui va durer des
décennies des siècles des millénaires sa
crise c'est un mot qui convient pas bien
mais oui il y a un petit effort
sémantique à faire on est rentré encore
une fois dans un dans un système de
dérive moi j'aime bien le mot dérive
parce que dérive on voit bien que ça
bouge on voit bien qu'on le maîtrise pas
trop c'est-à-dire qu'à court terme on
peut pas y faire grand-chose la dérive
le courant par exemple la dérive c'est
donc cette dérive que nous annonce
depuis 20 ans et dans lesquelles nous
vivons jour l'annonce depuis beaucoup
plus longtemps que ça vous avez en fait
les premiers les premiers travaux
scientifiques sur le réchauffement
climatique on va en fêter le
bicentenaire dans un an ces choses est
Fourier en 1824 qui a écrit dans un
journal scientifique de l'époque qu'il
existait en effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère et c'est dans le courant du
19e siècle que des physiciens et
physiciennes ont identifié les gaz qui
en étaient à l'origine c'est-à-dire la
vapeur d'eau et le gaz carbonique et
c'est à la fin du 19e siècle le premier
calcul d'ordre de grandeur sur le
réchauffement climatique qui suit un
doublement du CO2 dans l'air a été
effectué est-ce que on constate je
dirais scientifiquement la disparition
des saisons est-ce que les saisons
existent encore alors les saisons
existent encore
que l'inclinaison de l'axe de rotation
de la Terre sur le plan de l'orbite ne
changera pas et il est pas prêt de
changer de main matin il change un peu
au cours du temps mais pas la même
vitesse il y aura des saisons il
continuera y avoir des saisons ces
derniers continuera à y avoir un hiver
plus froid que l'été ça c'est absolument
certain par contre voilà là vous m'en
citer de
ce qui se dit dans les simulations
aujourd'hui c'est que dans un climat qui
se réchauffe la longueur de l'été va
augmenter la longueur de l'hiver va
fortement se raccourcir et la longueur
du printemps et de l'automne va se
raccourcir également intéressant il est
trop tard pour s'inquiéter donc la
question c'est comment on agit c'est
exactement la bonne question donc il y a
plein de d'abord il faut mieux
comprendre le problème aujourd'hui on en
est pas encore au niveau des décideurs à
avoir fait le tour il y a une énorme
différence entre avoir compris qu'il y
avait un problème et l'avoir
suffisamment bien compris pour le gérer
si vous êtes malade je comprends qu'il y
a un problème je n'ai pas suffisamment
compris le problème pour savoir si je
vais devoir m'occuper de votre nez de
vos oreilles de vos intestins ou votre
pied gauche ben là c'est exactement
pareil en ce qui concerne la dérive
climatique d'abord il faut bien
comprendre le problème pour s'y attaquer
c'est pas moi ça veut dire que quand on
dit ce sont les activités humaines qui
sont en cause on n'a rien dit alors on a
tout dit rien dit exactement parce que
il faut voir de quoi en gros il faut
voir dans quel ordre est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à changer les choses à quelle
vitesse on peut arriver les changer avec
quelle contrepartie on vit en démocratie
donc il suffit quand même d'expliquer
aux électeurs quel choix on peut faire
etc mon sentiment c'est que la classe
politique a toujours quelques années de
retard sur l'opinion de façon un peu
structurelle c'est ça c'est le cahier
des charges de la démocratie mais il
faut quand même que l'électorat
comprenne ce qui se passe et comprennent
suffisamment ce qui en est à l'origine
pour savoir où on peut agir et par
ailleurs en ce qui concerne les
conséquences qu'on ne pourra plus éviter
parce qu'il y a une inertie absolument
extraordinaire il faut savoir par
exemple que les calottes polaires ont
commencé à fondre et ça maintenant c'est
inarrêtable pour des milliers d'années
quoi qu'on fasse donc l'océan mondial va
continuer à monter pendant des milliers
d'années quoi qu'on fasse plus ou moins
vite en fonction de ce qu'on va décider
bon ça c'est des choses auxquelles il va
falloir s'adapter et il va falloir
s'adapter pas avec une semaine de
préavis c'est-à-dire que le jour où le
niveau de l'eau monte enfin sera monté
de quelques mètres pas tout de suite
quelques siècles c'est pas en une
semaine que vous allez déménager
Bordeaux ou une partie de Dunkerque donc
il y a beaucoup d'anticipation à avoir
dans un certain nombre de choses
l'anticipation en démocratie c'est
compliqué aussi donc il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'il faut expliquer il faut y
passer du temps en gros la première
conclusion qu'on peut avoir c'est qu'il
faut y passer du temps il faut regarder
le sujet dans le détail donc ne pas
hésiter à vous donner la parole et même
à revenir sur des questions qu'on a
l'impression d'aborder régulièrement
mais merci non j'ai bien compris
je vous laisse conclure mais mais il y a
quelques mois par exemple j'avais appelé
à ce que le nouveau gouvernement suive
une formation de 20h etc je l'ai
toujours pas vu en ce qui concerne les
membres du gouvernement et voilà par
exemple un premier pas qui serait utile
merci merci beaucoup jean-marjokovici
d'avoir pris la parole une fois de plus
sur RTL il est 8h28 bonne journée à vous